don't petty GRU its chief executive
National Grid joins me now John good
evening to you imagine you weren't
overly excited at Jeremy Corbyn saying
he wanted to nationalize you know know
so I mean interesting now I I started in
the industry about a couple of months
after privatization so I've seen the
evolution over the last 20 odd years of
the innovation in the cost reduction so
not really actually operates about 40
percent lower in cost compared to when
the government last owned the industry
so no we don't think it's particularly
good value for taxpayers to pay tens of
billions of pounds to renal eyes a
company like National Radio any of the
other energy companies and the other
thing is you've got huge investment
plans which so nationalization wouldn't
be the end of it
the taxpayer would subsequently paying
out to meet all your investment patents
position if you look at the National
Infrastructure Commission you know
recently did a report that talked about
a hundred billion pound investment of
the next decade in energy so that would
need to be paid for by tax payers who it
was nationalized so you know what we
need in the energy sector is stable
regulation and clear energy policies
from government to attract inward
investment to deliver thats 100 billion
pounds of investment we need have you
had any communication from Labour about
this because I mean National Grid is a
lot of people won't realize you're also
you have a colossal US business you're a
big energy supplier over there if you're
nationalized presumably labour isn't
going to be interested in those parts of
the business well I'm not sure that you
ought to be too keen on being
nationalized either so for us you know
40 percent of our businesses in the US
so you know we got a market cap of 40
billion and 40 percent of that is in our
US businesses so we haven't had any
conversations with labour about it and
as I said you know we don't think it's a
sensible proposition for energy
customers or for tax payers so what do
you make of the Conservatives proposals
for a cap on energy bills does that have
any implications for you it does have a
huge implication I mean I guess we
understand why the government would be
looking at energy bills you know it's a
big part people sort of disposable
income that they spend every week from
National Grid's perspective you know we
were the people that deliver the energy
it accounts about 3 to 5 percent of the
bill so for a typical household that's
got a thousand pounds or a dual fill
bill the national adele makes up about
45 pounds of it so you know from our
perspective our folks is always about
trying to minimize costs and you know
this year we've announced a number of
things that we're doing to reduce the
cost for customers
but you know it's that three to five
percent is the part of the bill that we
make up and our focus and making sure
that we invest to make sure the
infrastructure is safe and reliable and
to support some of the new energy that
every wants to connect in the network
that's already been quite a busy year
whew off gem a couple of months ago
decided against breaking you up it's
that issue off the table now as far as
you're concerned yes we came to an
agreement with with the government and
off GM their owns they talked about a
break up is actually our System Operator
rule which makes up about 1% but
operating profits or break ups not quite
the right word you know it's one part of
National Grid and and there were a
couple of issues in the market where
they wanted increase separation so what
we've agreed with off Jim and the
government is to increase the separation
put separate board over that part of the
business so that it's very clear that
it's segregated but it will remain part
of National Grid as a business going
forward but is it appropriate though for
you to be overseeing the balance in the
air in the in the grid in the network
whilst at the same time you are building
your own energy supply business to an
extent by importing you've got these
interconnected businesses I mean people
have talked about a sort of perceived
conflict of interest but the reality is
there's never been a conflict of
interest we're very careful at making
sure that we segregate different parts
of the business and you know the
investment that we're making in its
connectors are totally separate from our
regulated business and from our system
operations the other thing that you want
to do is be allowed to invest in
electricity storage which you're not
allowed to do so currently why is that
so at the moment storage in the UK's
clusters generation and gnash word is
precluded from owning generation in the
UK it's very different in the u.s. we
can own storage in the US my position is
very clear you know storage is a new
technology in order to drive the prices
down you want to give it access to as
many markets as possible and we're
suggesting that storage could be an
alternative in certain circumstances
reusing infrastructure so why not let us
use it and that will help drive prices
down all right John Pettigrew I'm afraid
we're going to leave it there really
appreciate you joining me thank you